we've got one of the highest
concentration of category 3 hoods and in
the country we're opening all of these
now high freq over 90 degrees in a
high-security lab at Liverpool School of
Tropical Medicine they're testing
samples from doctors and nurses on the
front line this new style of test isn't
for the coronavirus itself but for
antibodies people make in response to
the infection a positive result would
show they're recovering and safe to
return to work it's made by melodic and
it's one of the first prototype antibody
tests to be validated as part of a
clinical trial we need to be sure that
these tests are both sensitive so
they're able to pick up everyone who's
been infected and also importantly
specific so we don't want the test to be
positive when in fact they haven't been
exposed to the virus so it's very
important to understand how the tests
are working we're telling people that
they've been infected and they're
recovered but in fact they're still
vulnerable though they still don't have
any immunity to disease then that's
going to be disastrous especially of
those people of front-line health care
workers for example it takes just 10
minutes and it only needs a finger prick
of blood but unlike the current test for
the virus which only works when people
are ill the antibody test shows whether
they've been infected and perhaps not
even developed symptoms it could prove
crucial in controlling the pandemic
loosening the lockdown would allow us to
get back to work and lift the economy
but without mass testing public health
doctors wouldn't know how and where the
virus was spreading so this could be a
game-changer the government has said
it's buying three and a half million
antibody testing kits from different
suppliers but the chief medical officer
has warned against rushing them out a
bad test is worse than no test at all we
need to make sure that once these
technologies exist that we have the
manufacturing capabilities lined up to
produce as many as we can in the shorter
space of time but also that we have
access to these technologies here in the
UK but also globally especially in
lowest resource settings the company
hopes to make eight million kits a year
for less than a pound each
enough to control the pandemic even in
developing countries Thomas More Sky
News Liverpool